And then lastly, we just wanted to touch upon some material functionality, slightly more
complex again, but as you'll see, it's very straightforward if we're layering up these
approaches and learning about each step as we go. So we'll cover what material functions
are, we'll talk about using function inputs, we'll talk about building an animated material
function, and then we'll also use that material function in some form of master material.
So what is a material function? So material function allows you to embed materials within
materials, avoiding unnecessary clutter. It also just allows for reuse in various other
projects, packages, multiple materials. It's kind of reusing that functionality so you
don't have to keep creating or coding the same thing over and over again. So if you
get a really nice simple grass wind shader, for example, in this example, or you've created
a really nice water shader that you really want to reuse throughout your projects. Material
functions are a really nice clean way of saying, here's some complex piece of information.
I mean, it can be lightweight, but generally it'd be something a bit more complex, where
you've created this functionality and you can just use this as a function to plug into
an existing material to get the desired results. So you don't have to keep reworking existing
work. So we can use function inputs. So function inputs allow us to create some kind of customized
data, and we can edit the sorting priority, which allows control on where the new node
is and placed within the material function and the material destination. So how to create
this is that we want to first create a material function. And you can just do this by right
clicking in your content browser. Generally where you'd store other materials, maybe you'd
create a material function folder specifically, so you know where all your material functions
are. Again, it's just dependent on what your preferred workflow is. Essentially, you just
want to right click and go to materials and textures and create the material function
from there. Then you can open it up and create the system. So this is an in class exercise.
So we can go through this in the in class portion. However, even though there's a lot
of nodes going on, it's definitely not as hard as it seems. We provided samples. And
based on the previous example that we covered in the previous section, you can see that
it's a lot of copy and paste that information. So we've set up one section, and then we just
duplicated it and we're trying to dial in the desired results. So always just break
down the material to its component parts, kind of work backwards. And you'll see that
a lot of the information is then duplicated and replicated in different ways to achieve
this result. And so once we've created that material function, we can actually just use
that in a different master material now. So we can select the main material node and change
the material domain to light function. So this is the main material node here. So we
just want to click this pillar here of inputs. And you just want to on the on the left hand
side here, you'll see that we've got a light function material set up here. And that just
makes sure it cast shadows. You want to make sure that that's enabled. And then we can
call up the material function in the graph. And we can technically just drag it in. So
if you wanted to select it in your content browser and drag it in, or we want to specify
that we want to assign this MF four way motion or two, if that's what you called it in your
project. So by default, you'll just create a material function and then plug in the specific
function that you want into that node. Or you can drag and drop it in. So you just want to
for this example, you want to create a text quad and a scalar pram to multiply in the
material function. We've used all those before. And then we want to connect the caustic softer
texture to the texture node and then into the emissive. You'll see that we've only got the
emissive channel available to us now, because we went into that light function material
type. And so it just accepts emissive colors. So once we've done that, we can just connect
our light under the light function in the editor. And that should be working as some
kind of caustic style material in your editor. So just to cover that last section again,
when you have a light in your scene, all lights, if they're some kind of dynamic light, will
have a light function option. You can just plug this material into that light function in the
details panel. And that would add a caustic effect to the specific light. So if you follow
along in class and create this material function, master material that will give you a really
nice introduction to mass materials, again, slightly more complex concept. It's just getting
familiar with each module as you go. But you'll see that it's a lot of the replicated
information. You just build on upon your knowledge base. Try not to let it feel too complex and just
break it down to its component parts and just build from there. And then to close out here,
we've just got a few additional resources if you want to read up on any documentation. So whether
it's the introduction to materials, animating some UV coordinates, even just a high level
introduction to materials and material nodes, all that documentation is available to you.